oh my god my name is Rocco and I am a
man of trans experience recently a law
was passed that mandates the trans
people use the bathroom noted on their
birth certificate so to show how absurd
this law is we're putting it to the test
in Los Angeles California basically
seeing if people would be uncomfortable
with me in the women's room or even if
people are uncomfortable with me in the
men's room let's see if anyone is
comfortable with the trans person using
the bathroom
to him I can to be like why is there
dude in here I did it hot if you didn't
know me and we were in a public space
would that be uncomfortable I would be
very confused especially if I was in
there alone and it was just him and me I
dig okay this is a little threatening
but if it was you I'd be fine
I was a little surprised super relieved
I wasn't pooping if you weren't at work
would you have felt differently seeing
him in in the restroom probably would
have felt a little confused
but I know you so it was a little
different it seems like people have
buzzfeed are fine with whatever bathroom
I want to use but let's see what people
on the streets of Hollywood think in
North Carolina they just passed a bill
that doesn't allow trans people to use
the bathroom of their choice legally
they'd like for me to use the women's
room if you identify as a man and you
were in the woman's bathroom that makes
me comfortable if I was in the women's
room would that be jarring for you yeah
but if you look like a man and I come
out I will probably go with the police
or something
like what's going on would you be fine
with me being in the men's room with you
it's fine cuz I'm used to that I
wouldn't care honestly I don't think
anyone would question it anyway
ultimately we're all in separate stalls
it's not like you're right next to me I
don't know what she's doing
how would it really affect me if I went
in one song or another you know it was
heartening to hear that people feel that
trans people should be able to determine
what bathroom they want to use
comfortably I would be interested to see
if everyone felt differently if I was a
trans woman that didn't pass as well I
think that the reaction I would have
gotten would have been really different
when we're thinking about these laws in
abstract it's easy to explain why they
were put into place but when someone is
face to face with physical reality of
using a restroom it looks really
different and trans people shouldn't
have to pay the price for the fact that
there are sexual predators out there
laws like this support the idea that
there's something wrong with trans
people and that they don't deserve a
safe place to use the bathroom and if
anything trans people are the victims of
not having a safe place to go to the
bathroom